[Music]
slender man or that lanky faceless
tentacle wielding child stealing
teleporting creeps that's been haunting
our dreams for the last few years has
been traipsing across various electronic
mediums from its humble form beginnings
the figure has spawned endless fan art
from online artist communities fan
videos mockumentary
films and range of videogames Slender
Man is evolved into many different forms
through various threads turning him into
a community created terror that refuses
to leave us alone but what is it about
him that keeps us so intrigued
slenderman's creation began in something
Awful's forums in June of 2009 by user
victor serge two old photos of random
kids contained a tall dark creepy guy in
the background purposely vague to allow
for audience interpretation he has
typically portrayed as a tall thin
figure with a featureless head and a
black suit the photographs inspired
hundreds of stories found on forum
threads adding to the myth and horror of
Slender Man early stories depicted him
as dangerous and physically violent over
time though a second version of Slender
Man appeared one who was more passive
aggressive inflicting damage mentally
slowly forcing a victim to fall into
madness a few short weeks after the
character debuted a video series called
Marble Hornets appeared on YouTube
showing a behind-the-scenes of a film
project that slowly unravels into a
series revolving around Slenderman over
time thousands of Slender Man stories
emerged most of which seemed to focus on
the protagonist being haunted by the
tall cloaked shadowy figure three years
after those fateful forum posts youtuber
agent parsec created slender the eight
pages a simple unity based horror game
that places you on the terrifying turf
of the mysterious killer the dark woods
armed with nothing but a flashlight the
user has to find eight pages randomly
placed throughout the area each note you
get shortens your site and Slenderman
becomes increasingly aggressive video
and audio distortions add to the feeling
that he is somewhere near you all the
time and you get an incredible feeling
of helplessness and fear from the
paranoia that he's watching you and
planning your eventual demise
the sequel to the eight pages slender
the arrival released in 2013
similarly to the first game you get
nothing but a flashlight and the ability
to run to avoid your imminent doom but
the arrival offered something new a bit
more story and context the story about a
woman named Lauren investigating the
disappearance of her friend story about
strange discoveries of other
disappearances and eventually about how
all the people who had interactions with
Slender Man had subsequently exhibited
erratic terrifying behavior and this is
where Slender Man gets really
interesting because what you start to
understand is Slender Man himself isn't
the main thing to fear it's what happens
to people once they encounter him how
frightened and crazed they become in
their obsession with him
what makes Slender Man such a terrifying
monster is what he can make you become
as a result of your experiences and
state of mind a mistake that some people
had taken so seriously it's had
real-world consequences when two girls
from Wisconsin stabbed a classmate 19
times and claimed it was an offering for
Slender Man
now obviously Slender Man doesn't make
people kill and creepypasta doesn't make
people kill Slender Man is just a
fictitious character and this is an
anomaly so why are people so interested
thunderman is so popular in mainstream
media not because he's the ideal villain
for the internet because he was created
by the Internet within a few quick years
a simple forum post have so much
backstory that the world was able to
mould Slenderman into whatever they
feared the most
think about Bloody Mary or a monster
under the bed what's so frightening is
the unknown so we fill the gaps with
whatever scares us the most Slenderman
is ambiguous on purpose
so that we decide what's so terrifying
about him new Slender Man stories are
constantly being
and with the recent port of the arrival
to current gen platforms and a likely
sequel on the way
seems like Slenderman will be constantly
supplying us with a way to get scared
Slenderman doesn't look like he'll be
going away anytime soon and you get to
decide what's so frightening about that